>> Chris: THERE WAS SOMETHING OF
A PLAYGROUND SPAT GOING ON
TONIGHT BETWEEN TWO OF OUR
COUNTRY'S TOP POLITICAL LEADERS,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN ARE ARGUING
OVER WHO COULD KICK THE OTHER'S
BACK SIDE.
GIVEN THAT TRUMP IS 71 AND BIDEN
IS 75, A PAY-PER-VIEW CAGE MATCH
IS PROBABLY OUT OF THE QUESTION.
CORRESPONDENT PETER HAS THE
REACTION TONIGHT.
>> Peter: IT'S LIKE WWE HAS
TAKEN OVER D.C.
ROUND 1, TUESDAY IN MIAMI.
ROUND 2, TODAY ON TWITTER,
PRESIDENT TRUMP BOUNCED BACK.
JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO ACT LIKE
A TOUGH GUY, YET HE IS WEAK
MENTALLY AND PHYSICALLY.
YET HE'S THREATENED ME WITH
ASSAULT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW HE BUT HE WOULD
GO DOWN FAST AND HARD CRYING ALL
THE WAY.
DON'T THREATEN PEOPLE, JOE.
THIS IS THE CLOSEST WE'VE COME
TO SEEING POLITICIANS IN BOXING
GLOVES SINCE MITT ROMNEY DID IT.
BUT THAT WAS FOR CHARITY.
THIS IS -- LIBERAL WRITERS, ONE
HEADLINE, HEY, JOE BIDEN, YOUR
MACHO FANTASIES ABOUT A TRUMP
BEAT-DOWN DON'T HELP WOMEN.
ALSO A WASHINGTON POST ARTICLE
TITLED:  JOE BIDEN AND THE CASE
AGAINST TOXIC MASCULINITY.
>> I DO A MILLION OF THESE A
DAY.
>> Peter: HE MAY HAVE A SEED
ADVANTAGE IF THEY WENT AT IT, AS
FOR TRUMP, WE'VE SEEN HIM SWING,
JUST NOT IN THE RING.
ALTHOUGH HIS BODY SLAMMING HAS
BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED.
IT'S TOUGH TO HANDICAP A
TRUMP-BIDEN BOUT SO WE ASKED
SENATOR ORRIN HATCH FOR HELP.
>> I'D FEEL BAD FOR BIDEN.
HE'D BE RIGHT THERE IN THE
FIGHT.
>> ON THE COUNTER PUNCH, THEY GO
AFTER HE, I GO AFTER THEM.
>> Peter: LIBERALS --
>> I HAD TWO OLD COUCHITY UNCLES
USED TO DO THAT AT FAMILY
DINNERS.
I THINK IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THAT, I GUESS.
>> Peter: REPUBLICANS SAY THIS
WOULD BE FAR FROM THE THRILLA IN
MANILA.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
BE A BIG AUDIENCE ON PAY PER
VIEW.
>> Peter: AS IT TURNS OUT, TRUMP
V. BIDEN MAY JUST BE THE
UNDERCARD.
>> I'LL SAY THIS, I THINK
MELANIA COULD TAKE THEM BOTH.
>> Peter: CAN YOU IMAGINE IF WE
PICKED A PRESIDENT BASED ON WHO
COULD BEAT UP WHOM?
IT SOUNDS BARBARIC.
ON THE PLUS SIDE, IT'S HARD TORE